e
[Música]
você pode dizer que o ser humano gosta
de fazer coisas maiores com o tempo mas
eu tenho certeza que você acaba se
esquecendo que a terra não está
crescendo e a nossa população está em
ascendência ano após ano e isso só me
faz pensar em como nós deveremos
compactar e fazer do Futuro compacto a
nossa realidade
bom quando eu pergunto para vocês o que
o macro eo micro é uma coisa vem na
cabeça de todos os nossos unidades de
medida a
quilômetros metros centímetros coisas
que usamos no nosso cotidiano porém
existe uma unidade de medida da qual nós
não conhecemos tanto no meu número que
me interessa muito
eu não consigo mostrar para vocês o que
o nanômetro é porque ele é invisível
olho novo porém eu consigo dar algumas
relações e alguns exemplos por exemplo e
um metro existe um bilhão de Nonô metros
a gramatura de uma folha de papel tem
100 mil nanômetros e o diâmetro de um
fio de cabelo tem entre 80 a 100 mil
nanômetros
e com certeza nós já tivemos grandes
avanços tecnológicos até agora como por
exemplo os computadores que nos levaram
até a Lua
e
eles não são quase nada perto de água
que nós levamos em nossas mãos bolsas
algo portátil o nosso celular mas muito
mais fácil e mais impressionante de tudo
isso é que a mãe natureza começou a se
desenvolver deste ponto evoluindo do
micro até o macro a tecnologia com toda
a certeza se faz presente na nossa vida
das mais diversas formas como na tela e
comunicação na educação no trabalho na
medicina em todos os outros cenários
possíveis na medicina por exemplo onde
do robôs atualmente são usados para
fazer cirurgias muito mais eficazes e
precisas ou no desenvolvimento de novos
medicamentos
e a população mundial a última preocupa
muito por exemplo e 2015 a população
mundial era de 7.3 milhões de pessoas já
em 2021 no ano que estamos agora a
população mundial é de 7.9 bilhões de
pessoas mas os cientistas estimam que
até 2040 a população mundial vai ter
passado de 7.9 com acréscimo de 1.2
bilhão para 9.1 bilhões de pessoas
e a superpopulação realmente é um
problema muito sério alguns países já
perderam seu controle e manter a sua
população e o número estável sem crescer
altos números outras tomam medidas
totalmente drásticas para para isso em
alguns países como tudo é seus sonhos
tem o seu crescimento natural negativo
porém com o avanço tecnológico e com a
estabilidade da expectativa de vida e o
incentivo o crescimento da natalidade
esses crescimentos na esses crescimentos
naturais podem voltar a ser positivas a
qualquer momento
o que a sua população das grandes
problemas para todos nós por exemplo
instabilidade Econômica nesses países ou
regiões uma saúde precária a miséria e
Entre várias outras coisas como por
exemplo saneamento básico mas como
malthus defendia algum dia viveremos na
pobreza e na miséria e toda a comida que
produzimos não vai ser deficiente para
todos nós de fato existem muitas pessoas
que morrem de fome mas é interessante
pensar que hoje produzimos um ponto
cinco vezes a comida necessária para
todos nós E mesmo assim pessoas morrem
de fome todos os dias e esse número Só
vai aumentar
claro que para quase tudo há uma solução
e para esse problema Felizmente há uma
solução o minimalismo e as pequenas
tecnologias elas são extremamente
importantes e entrelaçadas com isso é
claro que você não precisa viver sem ter
nada mas você pode sempre se fazer a
pergunta tudo que eu tenho é necessário
eu preciso de eu tenho o posso
simplificar na minha vida as pequenas
tecnologias elas vão ser presença nossa
vida você querendo ou não mas
eu tenho certeza que não importa o que
você faça e não importa o jeito que você
use para trazer futuro compacto para sua
vida você terá uma vida mais saudável
como por exemplo usando a palavra
reinicialização um novo maineset podemos
repensar
reinicializar as nossas amizades os
nossos pensamentos os nossos valores e
as nossas escolhas de vida e assim
trazendo uma vida mais saudável da
pandemia percebemos a importância do
espaço ficamos presos angustiados e com
o avanço tecnológico e com a pergunta o
novo mais 7 podemos trazer uma vida mais
confortável sem uso do espaço sem uso
tanto espaço que nós usamos e pegamos
todo tanto início podemos fazer uma vida
muito melhor para todos nós mas o que
podemos fazer para um futuro mais
saudável E como eu já tinha dito podemos
fazer grandes várias coisas sendo
minimalismo as pequenas uso das pequenas
tecnologias um novo mais 7 entre todos
os outros tipos de coisas porém eu tenho
certeza que nós podemos mudar o nosso
pensamento com várias outras milhões de
pessoas e Usufruir do Futuro compacto ou
nós podemos continuar de fazendo o mundo
e levando todos nós para um fim muito
obrigada e
E aí